[Music]
thank you for turning up for this
discussion my name is philip ball and um
i'm the
the
chair for today um
and we're going to be talking about
whether change is needed to our
fundamental understanding of the
universe since the 1970s
we've understood the world through the
lens of the standard model and its
account of the forces and particles that
make up the universe
the theory correctly predicted the
discovery of quarks
force particles and most recently the
higgs boson but a series of deep puzzles
have emerged the theory does not explain
gravity
dark energy or dark matter and the quest
for super symmetry and a theory of
everything
uh to simplify the standard model's
seemingly random complexity has failed
and now even more significantly evidence
has emerged of a new force that is
throwing the whole theory into question
so can the standard model be modified to
answer the increasing number of
challenges it faces or is the standard
model fatally flawed and is it time for
the next great paradigm shift to a
radically different account of the
universe alternatively should we
conclude that all theories have their
limitations and not worry about the
flaws however profound they might be
so to our speakers um sam henry is a
renowned particle physicist physicist
working at the university of oxford he's
authored several academic papers
as well as maintaining his own blog and
running several science outreach
programs
sabina hossenfelder is a theoretical
physicist she's also the author of lost
in math how beauty leads physics astray
which explores the concept of elegance
in fundamental physics and cosmology and
virtually uh today we have uh bjorn
eckeberg he's an oslo based philosopher
of science who researches the limits of
scientific knowledge and his book
metaphysical experiments is a critical
exploration of the historical
foundations of physics and cosmology
so we're going to begin i'm going to
begin uh by asking each of the three
speakers to put across uh the case that
they want to make in this discussion um
to address this fundamental question
that we're asking is the standard model
fatally flawed and is it time for the
next great paradigm shift um so first of
all um i'm going to go to sam too
i do like the sound of a next great
paradigm shift because although particle
physics is never dull at the moment we'd
really like to see a bit more excitement
it's been 12 13 years since the large
hadron collider turned on and we found
the higgs boson and we then hoped that
we'd see more discoveries supersymmetric
particles dark matter some sort of new
physics beyond the standard model but we
haven't seen anything like that
in a way the problem with the standard
model is not that it's flawed but that
it's too good nearly every measurement
that we've made has matched the standard
model prediction perfectly but we know
that the standard model can't be the
final theory because there are too many
unanswered questions that are going to
need some sort of new science to explain
so two of the big ones are dark matter
and the matter anti-matter asymmetry we
know the majority of the mass of our
galaxy can't be explained with known
forms of matter so there must be some
new invisible particles out there or
else something else that we don't yet
understand
the standard model predicts that
particles and antiparticles are so
symmetric that they should have just
annihilated after the big bang and the
universe that we see shouldn't exist so
there must be some subtle asymmetry that
we don't yet know that can explain why
we're here
since we know the standard model is
incomplete then we would expect to see
some cracks forming by now some
measurements that don't quite match the
theory and that's why the muon g minus
two result from this year was so
interesting the formula laboratory in
the u.s measured the g factor of the of
the mu on the measure of the magnetism
of this particle and they showed that it
didn't quite match the standard model
prediction so it could be a sign of
something new a new force we don't yet
know there never seems to be any
shortage of theories of physics beyond
the standard model we used to be able to
find lots of papers that were using
these theories to predict papers just
beyond the sensitivity of current
experiments
we then built better experiments did the
measurements we didn't see anything
so does this mean that these theories
are wrong well when you check the small
prints it's a bit more complicated there
were assumptions made in these
predictions and if you change these
assumptions these particles could still
exist just heavier and harder to find
but it's now getting harder to find
papers making clear predictions and
theories like supersymmetry that we were
once told would be the next big thing in
particle physics now seem to be
terminally out of fashion
at this point it'd be really great if
something unexpected happened if we saw
something that nobody predicted or some
radical new idea came along that would
really shake up the field and make it
exciting
but is that going to happen probably not
the less exciting interpretation is that
we were just too optimistic about what
we could see in the first 10 years of
the large hadron collider and some
variation of supersymmetry or another
established theory is going to be
correct but seeing its effects is just
going to need more data and maybe
another generation of experiments to see
that but a great paradigm shift does
sound like more fun
thank you sir uh savina do you think we
just have to to wait or is there have we
seen flaws in the standard model that
reveal something deeper
well i have to side with sam that
saying that the standard model is flawed
uh is
you know a little bit too harsh judgment
i would say because we know it works
perfectly fine
and indeed that's kind of the problem
we we would be happy if it turned out to
be more obviously flawed
so to say but we do certainly
know that it has some shortcomings so
interestingly uh i seem to see different
shortcomings than you do
so um dark matter for example it may be
a particle maybe it's not a particle so
maybe it's not necessary to change the
standard model at all it might it may be
something with our understanding of
gravity
um that's the problem the mu and g minus
two yeah it's kind of intriguing but i
mean for one it hasn't reached five
sigma that's the one thing and the other
thing is
as you certainly know it's a hideously
complicated calculation it might very
well be that there's just some problem
with the prediction from the standard
model
and that it doesn't actually hint
that we have to look for new physics
but there are other problems with the
standard model
one is
what you already mentioned
it doesn't contain gravity
so we know that
in some way we have to combine the
standard model with gravity because the
particles in the standard model do
gravitate we know it
but we don't really know how it works
so that's that's certainly a big
shortcoming so we need a theory which
which is called quantum gravity that no
one really has any idea what it looks
like and the other peculiar thing about
the standard model are the neutrinos
so the neutrinos particle physicists you
know who work on accelerators usually
don't talk about them much because
they're somewhat hard to detect
but the neutrinos
are really really puzzling because from
all the other particles on the standard
model we have a left-handed and a
right-handed version from the particles
that have masses but from the neutrinos
we've only ever seen the left-handed
version
and that's a problem because we need
both the left and the height right
handed versions to give masses to those
particles and we know they have masses
how does this come about
we know for this reason that there's
something missing in the standard model
either they have to be right-handed
neutrinos which are just so heavy that
we haven't seen them
or there's something weird with the
neutrinos and they're just different to
all the other particles in a standard
model and there's actually another
anomaly which was not on your
introduction
in
the allison d mini boon data
which
looks for neutrino oscillations that's a
signal for neutrino masses and that
signal cannot be explained with a
standard model and it's actually now at
six sigma last time i looked so that's
really really puzzling and indicates to
me very strongly that the standard model
has to be completed there are probably
some particles that are missing
but and here's the thing you don't
actually have to change the standard
model all that much to add a few more
particles you know you can continue
using the same mathematical framework
and i don't think it will really be a
big paradigm shift
i think
where the big paradigm shift is going to
come from
is another thing that particle
physicists like to forget is that the
standard model
deep down is based on a quantum field
theory which brings in quantum mechanics
on the entire measurement process
and how a measurement works in quantum
mechanics is something that physicists
never really understood and so that's
where i think the big paradigm shift is
going to come
from thank you um bjorn we're going to
talk uh turn to you and this question
the way it's posed is the standard model
fatally flawed you have made the point
that actually we should be thinking
about there being two standard models
there's a standard model of particle
physics but there's also a standard
model of the way we think about
cosmology and that they're not the same
thing so over to you
yeah thank you uh
so there is in in practice these two
overlapping spheres of standard models
we use a standard model also in in
cosmology and not just in
theoretical physics and the center model
in cosmology is more built on the big
bang theory with dark matter and dark
energy and
other building blocks on top of it
so since we're talking about the
universe and making sense of the
universe as a theme for the debate uh
i'd just like to point that out from the
outset that uh i may be speaking to more
of the problems i would see with the
standard model and cosmology
than
than in physics
and so from my point of view having
followed uh studied and followed this
discourse for over a decade the standard
model of cosmology looks uh quite flawed
uh in i would argue even deeply flawed
but you pose the question whether it's
fatally flawed
and so fatally flawed supposes the
science will sort of die out the moment
is shown to be wrong or inconsistent in
some way uh and this is a very idealist
notion
instead i would suggest it's actually
possible in practice and this is what's
happening is that the model is it can be
flawed
and it will keep persisting as
the only operative model because it's
the only one that's put to use
so in the sense the point i would like
to make is that the science and here i'm
talking about cosmology in particular is
kind of stuck
the paradox is that it relies on a
theoretical framework that struggles to
make
make sense of and fit some of these
observations that we're making
but the model itself is so entrenched
that very few cosmologists would want to
seriously reconsider it and
reconsidering it is very
hard work
so in a sense physics uh and especially
cosmology
have become dependent or path dependent
on the standard model
is uh how i view the situation so
it is in practice the one and only model
and some would claim that this is
because it's simply because it's right
uh maybe more modestly you could say
it's because it's the best one we have
uh i'd like to argue instead that it's
become
to fail the reality is it would take
enormous funding and work to develop an
alternative theory
that could explain all our observations
better than a model that has been put to
operative use for more than half a
century
and without all that collective work um
there will never really be a paradigm
shift
okay thank you bjorn well maybe we'll
get on to what such
alternative theory might look like uh
later on i think i want to start off uh
the general discussion by um thinking
about where we are at the moment uh and
how we got here because one often hears
talk about a crisis in physics or at
least in fundamental physics and
particle physics um and i wonder whether
that's actually true and if so why what
why is that the case why is it that we
have this model that we know does a very
good job of a lot of things but we know
that there it can't be the the final
word as as i think you've all said
and yet we're struggling to make
progress on that um it seems that it's
it's proved incredibly difficult to find
any hint
of where we how we develop it where we
go from here so why has the progress in
these fundamental questions of physics
seem to why does it seem to have stalled
recently sabine uh if you could talk
about that first of all
uh sure before i answer your question
though um for the benefit of the
audience i want to explain that we've
now mixed together two different
standard models there's the standard
model of particle physics which i
believe is what we were talking about
uh and what bjorn was talking about is
the standard model of cosmology
which is based on einstein's theory of
general relativity that's kind of a
different thing
it's more commonly called the
concordance model or lambda cdm so just
you don't get confused
so
yes about your question like what's
going on why we're not making progress i
think it's a combination of two things
um the one thing is i i guess that's the
obvious thing to say um the easy things
have been done
like a hundred years ago and as a
scientific discipline
becomes more mature it becomes more
difficult to see new things and so it
just takes more time
but i also think that physicists have
not been
as careful
in thinking about what they're doing as
they should have been so it's on the one
side there's a problem with uh theory
development
um
after the completion of the standard
model in the 1970s forces were
really really convinced that symmetries
are great and you can use symmetries for
everything and this is why they
constructed a whole new bunch of
theories
based on symmetry principles grant
unified theories supersymmetry as the
name already says and they looked for
evidence for them and didn't find it
and now i think
you know that they tried it was was all
well and fine but at some point they
should have learned the lesson because
they tried it it didn't work but they
never
learned it and so they just continue
doing the same thing over and over and
over again and build bigger and bigger
detectors and they keep not finding
something new so i think there's a
self-reflection missing
and
so these two problems kind of uh play
into each other because we have the um
theoreticians not being careful enough
thinking about what might be the next
prediction to look for then we build
experiments that don't find anything and
so we just you know continue to
um not make any progress
well sam you're involved in some of
those experiments so what's your
perspective on this question
yeah well first of all i'd like to say
that progress hasn't completely stalled
it's just not going as fast as we like
and maybe we're not seeing the kind of
progress that we really want but in
experimental particle physics you know
we are doing things 10 years ago we
didn't know the higgs boson existed
we've now done precision measurements of
its properties well maybe not precision
measurements measurements of its
properties and of the particles it
decays into and we're using it as a tool
to search for new particles i guess also
we're doing a lot of
searches and we're getting a lot of no
results searching for new particles and
effects but we don't see them and no
results are not as sexy as discoveries
but they're still an important part of
the scientific progress and let's not
dismiss the efforts of these teams you
know they're not going to win a nobel
prize but these students do deserve
their phds
but i think as sabina said it's true
that we've now reached a point where
where um there's there's uh i think it's
a bit of a disconnect between the theory
and the and the experiments one of the
problems is that the theory is so far
ahead of the experiments because by the
time
we reach a point where where we've built
a new a bit of apparatus it now takes so
long to build these accelerators the
theory has moved on so we find the
experiments we're doing were were built
the design was chosen based on the
theory 30 years ago which is obviously
not the best way to to do things and i
don't really see an easy solution to
this because these experiments are now
very difficult and they need huge
collaborations to do it's now even the
smallest particle physics experiments of
several hundred scientists and these
collaborations they take a lot of time
to put together into and to build the
the projects uh everything is getting
more complicated and the next upgrade of
detectors is a large hadron collider we
could be seeing a hundred uh protons
colliding at the same time that leads to
a thousand over a thousand particle
fragments flying out and you have to
keep track of every one to micrometer
precision just to have a chance of
identifying the signature as something
new so even the small sub detectors of
your component have teams of 100 people
working on it so yeah it's going to be a
lot more challenging and i don't really
have a solution to so i think maybe we
do need to rethink about the connection
between experimental physics and
theoretical physics well that touches
beyond on the the issue that you raised
about path dependence because you know
what sam has said is that
purely by the nature of this big science
uh
that is involved one has to commit
almost to a theoretical position
perhaps decades in advance of having the
experiments to test it
is there from
the point of view of a philosopher of
science is there a problem in that way
of doing science well there is a general
problem for um
the development of the sciences uh like
of of physics and cosmology this is part
of the historical picture is that it
comes up against certain limits so there
are fundamental limits
you know the history of science is this
amazing trajectory of how we are able to
uh
measure and expand our knowledge within
the universe but there are fundamental
limits that are always um
the history is about surpassing
uh and
i i think what both sabina and sam are
pointing to is that progress seemingly
stalls because we have this idealist
notion of progress from a century ago
and it's harder and harder to get
further into nature whether we're
looking in the microphysical scale or
further out into the universe
so in in this perspective too i want to
point out that the situation in
cosmology is a bit different from
uh particle physics
uh
in that like physics and the microscale
you can do experiments under controlled
conditions as
sam is pointing out in the macro
physical universe as we know it
we don't
we can't do
repeated experiments the same way and
we're talking about a scale here that is
20 orders of magnitude higher than the
scale of particle physics
so this leads to certain kinds of
problems just with
basically how confident we can be in our
own measurements about the scale itself
and so on so i think it's important to
keep in mind that
with this subject matter whether we are
looking inwards to
the inner part of particle physics or
outward in the in the uh
in the universe
is we are also fumbling
in a way we are fumbling in the dark uh
and we're using a map
which we are very afraid to let go of
because if we
tried to replace the map we would lose
we would risk being lost all together
and that is a very precarious situation
i mean this is part of my interest in
cosmology and in theoretical physics is
that it just exists that this limit of
what is knowable and i believe this is
what also sam and sabine find exciting
about this kind of work but yes it is
um there are some fundamental problems
here
i mean it sounds as though perhaps some
of the problem is that
understanding of this area is advancing
on these two fronts that are quite in
some ways quite distinct that as you
know as you say
uh
you can turn a telescope
onto a certain object in the sky and
make an observation tomorrow and as we
have found those sorts of observations
can fundamentally change the challenges
that theorists and perhaps even
experimentalists have to face so you
know no one was necessary i mean we've
known about dark energy we've known
about dark matter for some time now um
but you know that came out of
observations rather than any theoretical
motivation dark energy came as a
surprise uh back in the 1990s but you
know it's confronted high energy
physicists with a new problem a quite
you know deep fundamental problem that
wasn't originally on their agenda i
guess i mean does that create problems
that actually astrophysicists and
cosmologists can create problems for you
overnight you know whereas you've
already sort of launched on a particular
program of experimentation
i think that's yeah that's certainly
true that can be a problem and um
maybe the problem is that one field of
physics is often looking to another
field of physics to solve their problems
so the astronomers are all convinced
that dark matter exists and they're just
waiting for us to find it um but of
course as sabine has said there's many
possible ways of solving the dark matter
problem and you know new particles are
one way but there are also theories of
new physics and uh new gravity
modifications to gravity and uh it seems
uh i can't keep track of all of the
developments in theory it seems that
these things go in and out of fashion at
one time everyone thought it was
particle dark matter now it seems that
uh modified newtonian dynamics might be
coming back into fashion um but uh but i
think you know the astronomers they
don't they they just seem to say right
dark matter exists we've shown it you go
find it
right
okay
um well there's more we could say about
that but i want to move on to the to the
next topic that we want to which i think
follows on quite naturally from that uh
from that issue which is really to ask
how serious uh this problem is you know
you you said sam that um perhaps uh we
were too optimistic in what the large
hadron collider would find um and so far
it hasn't found for example any clear
evidence of the idea of supersymmetry
which people were certainly hoping was
going to be the next step forward so
and now we have the muon g minus two
results that you say you know suggest
that there may be something that we
don't really understand how
serious are those problems and in
particular with with supersymmetry i
mean is it causing panic amongst you
know uh particle amongst theorists that
there is no sign of it or
are they is it did they expect this to
be an extremely hard thing to to detect
um well maybe to first mention the the
anomaly we've seen which is the the muon
g minus two uh thing i mean what this is
showing us is that there's something
that's interacting with the muon but
that's not in the standard model and the
muon is a great particle to study
because it's it's heavy enough to be
sensitive to new physics but it also
lives long enough that you can actually
put it in beams and storage rings and
actually study it properly and so there
seems to be something that's either
interacting with the mu on or it could
be interacting with something that's
interacting with something that's
interacting with the mule and it could
be a second or higher order effect and
this could be a a new force but really
we don't know how it's best to describe
it it could be a new particle
interacting by an existing force or some
variation of an existing force and the
muon g minus two experiment is a
brilliant probe for searching for new
physics because it depends on so many
things but this also means that having
observed it we don't really know what it
means you know there's so many possible
theories that can explain it
supersymmetry was one but then
supersymmetry hasn't been seen at the
the large hadron collider so maybe we
need to look at at other theories and um
yeah when you look at these obviously
what does it tell us well we know that
the vanilla flavor of super symmetry
seems to be out but maybe some
alternative version of super symmetry
could still be correct but there seemed
to be no shortage of other theories
collusion climb particles extra
dimensions z primes leptoquarks uh
technicolor baryons the you know so many
theories that as an experimentalist
focusing on the hardware i can't keep up
with the ball so i just have to uh to
listen to people like sabina to tell me
which ones i should be paying attention
to well i was very struck by that that
how once as soon as this result came out
um the uh the the physics um community
in the pre-print server where physicists
post their papers were flooded with
theoretical explanations you know so
many that you you kind of have to wonder
how how constrained at all is this
problem if so many um
theoretical explanations for something
quite new can seemingly be cooked up
almost overnight um i mean sabine maybe
you can talk to that issue you know do
we really know uh what the problem is
you know is there too much room for
maneuver
yeah so that that's an excellent point
though i have to say as it's often the
case if there's a new result coming out
there are a lot of people who already
know it's coming so they they may not
have written the papers overnight and
they had some advance uh warning but
it's certainly true and that's exactly
what i mean when i say we have a problem
with theory development when you can
explain everything by your theoretical
methods
then
since you were asking you shouldn't pay
any attention to those predictions
they're entirely worthless and that's
what we see that's why they're being
ruled out over and over and over again
because you have all these theories they
literally guess their models because
they like one particular particle or
they like one particular symmetry or
they get obsessed with you know some
anomaly and astrophysics that's
currently on vogue and then the next
year it's gone and so on and so forth
and it just leads nowhere and i i really
think that theoretical physicists they
have to have a hard look at
their methods of theory development and
throw out what didn't work
but the problem is exactly what bjorn
said we have this path dependence and so
we have settled on a particular method
of
making new predictions if you want to
call it that way for new particles which
you can then rule out and that
works very easily if you've learned how
to do it like this is what i was trying
to do basically i know how it works and
that's how you can write papers and
that's how you get grants and that's how
you get your students and then the
students become professors so it just
goes on and on like this and if you want
to do something fundamentally new you'll
have to start over again from scratch
and it becomes very very hard to find
any support
one alternative to that um is and this
seems to be the one that's in the air at
the moment we need a bigger machine to
find out more um
you've expressed some skepticism about
that whether that's the right way
sabrina
uh yeah for exactly this reason i mean
we do know um as i think we all agree
that the the standard model has some
short comics and it has to be more to it
but there's no reason why building a
bigger machine would
give us any help in developing that
underlying new theory
all of those anomalies at various levels
of statistical significance
they
may be resolved at much much higher
energy so even if we build this bigger
collider
which they are planning for at cern and
would have a circumference of i think
100 kilometers and cost like something
like 20 billions not counting the
operation cost which would be another 20
billion or something so so we're talking
about a huge bunch of money and the
outcome may just be well the standard
model works just fine and i think
um that's a little too much money for
that little
prospective payoff which is why i think
we have to figure out what a more
promising experiments are to look at
where we can expect a bigger bang for
the buck so to speak
and beyond it occurs to me that this is
somewhere where the philosophy of
science might actually be helpful and
it's been interesting to me that
there has seems to be more dialogue now
between
high energy physicists fundamental
physicists and philosophers of science
to try to find some resolution to this
problem and one of the issues as you've
you've touched on is how you know
when
when uh you you just keep waiting
because you have a theory that seems to
do a lot of things pretty well and so
you don't want to throw it out you know
too casually and when you actually
decide no hang on a minute we need to
turn back we need to go back down the
path and rethink some of the
fundamentals
is there any guidance that the
philosophy of science can give to that
question
well i'm uh
i am also
positive about like i'm seeing
increasing dialogue in these fields
when it comes to the nature of evidence
for example
this is where it's it's worth noting
that we're talking here in the context
for example of dark matter or these
latest uh experiments
something like evidence is often banded
about and there's a
there's a sense in the field that
something has more or less been proven
something like dark matter is
taken by a lot in the scientific
community and beyond as just
more or less proven to exist and it's
worth pointing out that how the evidence
for something like dark matter comes
about is not in any direct empirical
sense in fact there is no direct
evidence of dark matter at all
it is an uh an inference
from the discrepancy that happens
between the theoretical model prediction
and the observations we make so the
basic assumption underneath a lot of
this is that uh the if the model that
we're using is correct there has to be
something like dark matter or a new
force or something to explain that gap
this is a familiar pattern in the
history of physics and this is
especially true i think in cosmology
that the more observations we make the
more discrepancies we find with model
predictions
the more cosmologists adjust or add
parameters to fit observations
or they propose additional hypothesis or
new physics or such as a new force and
or like in the case of this latest
experiment which is
all very exciting for scientists because
this means a path for more research
but it's just worth pointing out that
what a lot of these kinds of solutions
have in common is they also preserve the
core assumptions
they add on something or erase a new
question but they they uh
make the more fundamental or radical
questions
uh almost impossible to reach
and so
i think the philosophical view i mean
it's very limited i'm not in a position
to judge the merit of particular kinds
of evidence
but
if there could be
any help in asking
more fundamental questions about how we
got into the situation in the first
place might be helpful
right um sam i'm also wondering whether
um
is just a bigger machine the only
alternative the only um empirical
alternative we have for addressing these
problems i mean we talked a little bit
just beforehand about you know ongoing
work on the muon g minus 2 issue
using the the devices we have already
are there other ways that we can already
be seeking for a path forward uh without
having to build this even bigger
collider well i think that this is an
open question in particle physics at the
moment and so yeah there certainly is
this this uh plans for a future circular
collider but i think it's by no means
there's no means agreement among past
physicists about whether this is the
right way forwards um for the reasons
that spina has said that you know it may
well be that we build such a machine and
it doesn't actually find anything and
you know of course that's very difficult
to predict but we do want to focus on
the experiments that are most likely to
deliver an interesting result the
alternatives you know it could be that
yeah more precision measurements of
particle properties um could be
interesting things like the muon g minus
two experiment also measurements of the
electric dipole moments of of particles
this this is another way of doing
particle physics um but there's only so
many of these experiments uh that we uh
that we see at the moment i mean other
possibilities are maybe do we need to
look at ways of studying the ultra high
energy cosmic rays that are bombarding
the earth from outer space at energies
far higher than anything we could ever
reach with a with an accelerator we
build or do we want to study neutrinos
which are a completely different game to
studying other particles so there's all
sorts of different experiments that we
could be doing in the future and yes
this is an open question in the field at
the moment is what direction do we want
to go in and
maybe this is i think what we'd really
hope is that uh you know if we discover
some particles at the lhc and that
suggests that there's going to be more a
little bit further then that will build
on the case of building a bigger
accelerator if we don't discover
anything then i think it's quite likely
that people are going to listen to
theories like seven and say actually no
this is not the right way to go
and and then we but then there will also
be other people who'll say well we you
know we still need to to explore further
so you know there is a case for building
such a machine anyway because you know
we just need to explore to higher energy
scales and if we stop now we'll never go
further you know even if a new machine
doesn't see anything it would be at
least a technology demonstrator for the
one that may come after it but i think
that's going to be a very hard argument
uh to convince somebody to spend 20
billion on such a project right um i i
wonder before we we move on i'd like to
um just say a little bit more about the
dark matter problem because although
it's you know not the only clearly not
the only puzzle facing fundamental
physics it's probably one of the ones
that people hear most about and know
most about um and
you know here we've they've been
many searches for dark matter particles
that have still found nothing sabina do
you think that
we just
in in that particular case we just need
to keep looking or is there something
else we should be doing to try to
resolve this this issue of why we seem
confronted with a need for dark matter
well as bjorn said um the evidence that
we have for dark matter is uh indirect
um so we infer that there has to be
if you believe that it's some kind of
matter we infer it from astrophysical
observation gravitational lensing for
example or
galactic rotation curves motions of
clusters so we measure the velocity and
we just know that it doesn't work with
general relativity and the standard
model if you combine it it doesn't come
out right and adding a new type of
matter is the easiest way to resolve
this discrepancy between the observation
and the theoretical predictions
but
these observations are are very
unspecific about what exactly the
properties of this dark matter are
if it exists
so we don't really know what's the mass
of the particle we we don't know how it
interacts with itself um or with other
matter i mean we do know that it doesn't
interact with light because that's why
it's called dark but that's pretty much
it
and so if you know
that little about a particle it's really
really hard to build a detector for it
because you don't even know what you're
looking for
and so the reason we've built a
particular series of detectors actually
they're kind of two types of experiments
uh one type is looking for a type of
particle that's called a wimp a weakly
interactive interacting massive particle
and the other one is an axion and both
of these particle
types so they're actually classes of
particles you could say
were motivated by theoretical arguments
and that brings us back to the problem
with the theory development because you
can ask how well motivated
were they actually um so wimps in
particular were
very popular because they come out of
supersymmetry
so it brings us back to what i said in
the very beginning about how particle
physicists came to like symmetries
and the axions
they were predicted basically to
you know make the standard model a
little bit prettier
and the original version of the axion
actually was ruled out very very quickly
in the 1970s and what happened
afterwards
is that physics just made the theory
more complicated this is something by
the way which we see over and over and
over again
um bjorn already mentioned this that if
you have a uh some prediction that runs
into conflict with the experiment then
the theories just go and make the theory
more complicated so in the end it can
just accommodate um everything and
that's also what happened with the axion
and that's what happens now when every
time these dark matter experiments don't
see the particles that they were looking
for the theorists would just go oh it's
a little bit more massive it's a little
bit less strongly interacting and we'll
have to build a bigger collider
detector sorry
okay well finally i want to ask um why
does it matter why should we care and
it's lovely to see that presumably for
all of you you do care enough at least
to come and hear about it um but really
the the the question is you know if we
discovered i mean beyond for example you
know if we discover that you're right in
thinking we actually need to go right
back and really
fundamentally think about and perhaps
change some of the assumptions that have
brought us to this point so far in terms
of the standard model or the standard
models
would that significantly would that have
had wider implications philosophical and
social and i'm thinking here you know
that clearly in the past
changes in our cosmological worldview
have done the heliocentric uh theory did
seem ultimately to have broader
implications the the discovery of the
the big bang um you know arguably
changed our view of where we sit and
what our role is if you like in the
universe
do you think that uh there is the
potential here at least for that kind of
fundamental rethinking of our position
that reaches beyond questions that are
you know really only of interest to
specialists
well i think i've uh
tried to make here from the outset that
my own view on this is a little bit
skeptical of how major changes can come
about but
uh
to the question of whether it matters
and how it matters this of course does
depend on what we would change it to
what a change would look like or how
radical it is
uh as sabine just described i mean the
standard model uh the standard model of
cosmology that i've been looking at the
structure of is like a series of
building blocks on top of each other
it's a very very complicated
multi-layered theory uh it looks when
you map it out to like uh jenga if
you're familiar with this uh this game
or it's like multiple blocks that sit on
top of each other and if any of the
blocks underneath fail some of the other
ones will fall or you can replace one
and put another one dark matter is such
a
block somewhere in the middle of that
structure that there is another
contender for uh
which i know sabine is working a lot
with as well modified newtonian gravity
or mond in in short so
to put this in the in perspective if
what we call a paradigm shift is for
example that dark matter becomes
more or less abandoned and in favor
like that we move in favor of the
modified newtonian dynamics
if that were to overtake something i
doubt that it would affect many lives
outside of the scientific community it's
like
replacing one block with another
but if we are talking about
a new understanding of light or new
understanding gravity electromagnetism
or other forces
or even if we are questioning and
talking about the origin story that the
universe began in a hot and dense state
uh a paradigm shift like that would of
course have
enormous uh cultural impact
and i think
the point i would like to make is that
our understanding since we're talking
about the how we understand our universe
understanding relies on explanation
and the power of a theory traditionally
lies in
its power to explain something and when
you look at the field of physics and
cosmology the way it's developed over
the last century historically speaking
it's become better and better at
describing phenomena with more precision
and detail and layers and but it's also
become poor at explaining them and i
think this is this is part of the
problem that there's a a lot of people
inside and outside the scientific
community are finding
the current paradigm wanting for
something like it doesn't explain very
much for example if mon becomes
the favored theory over dark matter what
does it mean for example that
the implication that gravity is variable
at large distances which is what mond
presupposes that our laws of gravity as
we know them in our
in our own galaxies that don't actually
translate further what what is the
implication of that
that is
i suppose these are the kinds of
questions we can get to but
i am not sure if this alone warns a
major paradigm shift
in the context that you're discussing
here
sam i wonder about these issues um from
from your point of view as someone who's
working on these experiments that happen
of course in vast international teams
trying to look for things that are very
very hard to see and probably you know
making incremental progress in in in
doing so
is there sort of behind that quest is
there in you and your colleagues a sense
that actually you might find
something that really profoundly upends
our understanding of the way things work
is that part of
the motivation
well i think that's that's not something
we really expect to find because i guess
everything we do is always building on
everything that's happened over the last
20 or 30 years and so uh any changes
that we expect to see can probably be um
explained by just introducing another
particle into the standard model
but i suppose we always live in hope
that we're going to see something really
unexpected and i guess maybe what one
way we can imagine what might happen is
let's think back to
a great paradigm shift that never was
and that's ten years ago when for a
short period the opera experiments
convinced everyone that they just might
have seen neutrinos traveling faster
than the speed of light
and nobody believed it because you know
it would it was very difficult to fit in
with our existing framework but the idea
was just so exciting that for a short
period you know everyone it was all
people could talk about and and you know
how could we possibly you know rewrite
the laws of physics to accommodate that
and everyone really excited about it and
that was not just in the particle
physics community it also got a lot of
media attention the idea so you know
particle trapping cast and speed of
light got a lot of attention and so for
a brief period it was really exciting
and then of course it was a rather sad
end that it turned out to be a 40
electronic module and an optical fiber
not probably plugged in but i think that
at least gives us some sort of idea the
kind of excitement we'd see if there was
some sort of unexpected result that did
point at a that we need to completely
rewrite our whole framework
serena i get the impression um
from you
sometimes part of the motivation you
have for thinking about these things and
it seemed to be what you were sort of
saying in lost in math is that you you
you want to challenge the way
that
no i might be too broad to say the way
science is done but there are some
things about the way this science is
done that you feel could be done better
or differently
can you say something about that yeah
exactly um so
the oprah anomaly by the way was another
example where theoreticians were very
very quick to find all kinds of
explanations
um you know so which drives home the
point that it's fairly easy
with the current methods that are
currently accepted to explain pretty
much everything and so we talk about the
scientific method as if it was a fixed
thing but it's a living and evolving
thing and what counts as good science at
one point in the history might no longer
count as good science 100 years later
and i think that in the foundations of
physics um we have to ask like do we
need to update our methods and for me
the answer is clearly yes we have to we
have to be more careful
in our theory development more careful
to write down what the assumptions are
and to ask whether they are justified so
for example this conversation we're
having here i think it's great that
we're having it but i think
there should be more physicists having
uh this discussion but maybe if i can
say something about your question it
doesn't even matter which is kind of it
you know if you ask this question among
physicists is kind of blessed for me
uh is a question you're not even uh
supposed to ask but i i think you you
have to be more careful about adding
like does it matter for whom and when
so it clearly matters for particle
physicists you know if we don't build a
bigger particle collider that matters to
them
um but does matter to society
if you know we find a crack in the
standard model um if we find a new
particle that kind of thing and that
depends very strongly on
exactly what it is
so as i said earlier
physics is a very mature discipline and
the easy things have been done this also
means if we find something new it's very
unlikely to have an immediate impact on
daily life just because if it's
difficult to measure it's probably also
difficult to use
um so if you know we find some particle
that makes up dark matter i can't really
see what difference it would it would
make
for daily life
but there may be some
you know
consequences in the future you know you
just discard mond as something that
would never be of use to anybody but i
don't know you know if one day our
civilization manages space travel maybe
we should know how gravity works
can you please join me in thanking our
panelists today and thank you all for
coming too